[Music]
what does the coronavirus have to do
with mathematics ever heard the term
viral when we create a video at don't
memorize we hope that it will go viral
but what does viral exactly mean yes
it's true we want a whole lot of people
to view the video but look at this daily
chart of views recorded is it viral the
line is straight it's a linear growth
what we really aim for is exponential
growth but do you truly understand what
exponential means it is the rate of
change over a given time period it is
something we refer to in the real world
as compounding so if we get 1,000 views
on day one and each subsequent day we
get 20% more views day two we will have
1200 views day 3 will be 1440 views and
look at the staggering number on day 30
two hundred and thirty seven thousand
three hundred seventy-six views for the
same rate of growth with passage of time
the growth seen for each time period
increases immensely that is the power of
compounding that is exponential growth
viral infections spread in this manner
and hence anything which shows
exponential growth is referred to as
viral so let us see if this video goes
viral we are hoping it does do share
this video with your friends and check
back in a few days to see if there's an
exponential growth
[Music]